five four three two one welcome
everybody to another episode the genius
brain podcast we have a very Hispanic
guest today is super Mexican guest today
as Mexican as it gets
mm-hmm so Mexico she only wears red
white and green everywhere she goes she
peels out Passos Tiffany Del Rio
yeah hello everybody No Mas way of
learning espanol and Mexican and that's
never what she said
thank you David ever so that's not what
I said no that needs to stop existing so
there's this weird
JK films or does it JK news I don't even
know but it's like this weird JK films
reddit page and I found out through this
one time when I was on JK news and she
was mentioning something called fan fics
and fan fics fanfic Vic fanfic and
that's like we're fictional yeah so
fanfic is for it's like they create
stories and it's it's always sexual
right yep about whatever person that
could be a celebrity or somebody that
they know or some [ __ ] like that and
they have one for like the JK films
women yeah there was a video where byron
like we did a reaction video or
something like that i didn't know that
yeah because when you guys mentioned it
I was like okay let me see what this
[ __ ] is and do this a reddit page yeah
it's a [ __ ] reddit page it's it's a
weird [ __ ] I don't know I haven't seen
it recently but I did see it many years
ago I forgot how it was right here
yeah years cuz I remember I can't
remember how I came across it but I do
remember someone mentioning like oh
there's this fanfic about you and do it
and that's the first time I had ever
heard about that term too so then I
googled it and I was like oh my god they
had some like weird scenes with me I
just I don't even like to talk about it
I'm getting uncomfortable
that's [ __ ] crazy dude yeah they um
how does that feel them because I you
know what I always think about with you
is Bette because you came on later on
into the whole social media universe
right
because you you were just an extension
of Casey at that time yeah
and so I don't think your idea or what
you thought you would be doing would be
this murder so isn't it kind of weird
that there's people in sex stories about
you be fantasizing about you you know
what's crazy
so you know when they were doing the
deep fake stuff deep fake oh yeah yeah
yeah that's we did that on JK news that
where they would they superimpose this
celebrity's face yeah on a video like a
porn video or something yeah so I found
out that they did that of me as well and
the reason why I find out is because you
know motherboard Vice like Vice
motherboard it's like a news thing where
they talk about like online stuff so
they hit me up on Twitter saying hey we
want to interview you for this piece
that we're writing about around deep
fakes and I was like what the [ __ ] why
would they want to interview me and they
were like yeah you have one like how do
you feel about that I'm like what's up I
have one oh my god so then when I tried
googling it it was already taken down so
I got thank God but yeah they we do like
a phone interview and stuff and then
later on I looked up that article just
because I never got notified if I ever
went up or anything and I looked at the
article and they didn't use any of my
stuff where I'm like oh but it's okay
I'm good cuz I don't want to be you know
like tied to that stuff like that I
became hyper controversial because of
just like I get a teeth F or yeah Gary
just because like it's even though it's
not them it clearly it's fake it's still
like an invasion of their privacy okay
that's exactly what she was interviewing
me about like how do you feel that even
though this isn't your body it's still
your face in your image that's being
used for something like this and I was
just telling her I'm like it really does
feel like a violation because I it's
just it's not done with my consent
something it's so strange and I mean
this is probably why didn't used me for
the interview because I really couldn't
put into words like what it actually
feels like because I was mentioning to
how I have a son and he's 11 you know so
I'm like um I don't want his friends to
come across it or like him to come
across this stuff
and that's just a whole nother fear that
it reminds me of back in the day where
because I used to watch this show monk
did you ever see monk yeah so you know
how he had a like Sharona
the ways helping him so his assistant
and there was this one episode where she
took some like not noot like fully nude
photos but she did take some like in
lingerie
when she was really young and she had a
son and there was this whole episode
about how this guy had these photos
about her like of her and was trying to
blackmail her and she was just like my
son like I don't want him to be exposed
to this or whatever and at the end of
the episode it ended up being like she
had a conversation with her son about it
but I don't know for some reason that
episode really stuck with me and I saw
that even before I had an IQ of se
totally reminded me of that I'm like I
don't want my kid to be like he
shouldn't have to be exposed to that
especially because that wasn't even
something like I chose to even do like
that's something that someone even like
just did it I want somebody to make a
deep fake of me but on a better body I
would love that [ __ ] I would [ __ ] I
would be quite grateful but it better be
something highly inaccurate I wanted to
be like this buff ass body and I'm like
yep that is me that actual sex tape is
me it's my sex tape I'm doing my own
deflation sexy that she's yourself like
what what bastard would release this sex
tape of me getting my dick sucked by a
beautiful woman who would do such a
thing
and I want to advise to hit me up how do
you feel about it oh I feel so torn
I feel like if I had a kid I'd know
about this when you were it was
interesting because when we first met
like I don't think I knew about Isaac
until later on right
mmm cuz I don't I'm not sure if Isaac
Isaac what part was probably there but I
wasn't I didn't notice him until like
maybe the second or third time it was
like I mean you didn't even notice me
first like five times we met that's cuz
your chameleon dude that's not my
[ __ ] fault dude and you didn't talk
that much either you're a very timid and
[ __ ] yeah you were super timid and shy
and at that time too I didn't really
know Casey that well either I actually
you know out of all the JK guys Casey
was the first person that I met oh
really it was Casey that I met and I
spoke to and then case he introduced me
to Martin Jeff I did not know that yeah
so Casey was the first person I met in G
crazy where did you guys meet San Diego
Asian Film Festival and this is the
Casey that maybe you met too greasy
Casey oh yes
yeah yeah remember Casey had like the
long hair and the mustache earrings oh
yeah earrings does he still have the
holes where they closed up now I don't
know but I know he still has a hoop like
these tiny little hoop earrings and I'll
find them sometimes when we move or
whatever I'm like why do you still have
these he's like they're my hearing you
can't get rid of that type of stuff yeah
he used to say like yeah Michael Jordan
will wear it all the time I'm like that
was in the night you think move on man
it's our heroes dude we can't like move
away from them yeah well I actually met
both of them and when I met Bart and Joe
mm-hmm
I couldn't click who they were and then
when I was having a conversation I was
like [ __ ] I know who these guys are
because there was a video that they did
it was the Korean History Channel oh and
then me me and my cousins and my brother
were watching it over Thanksgiving I
think a couple years back before I met
them before I started doing you crazy I
was in tears [ __ ] laughing like it
was when I I and it was when I used to
go to Davis I don't go to the school by
you just go to Dave's just get drunk and
[ __ ] but a couple of my friends went
there and they showed me that video
there and then I brought it over to
Thanksgiving and my cousins I used to
laugh of that video all the time and so
I remember I was like dude I know who
you guys are and they're like oh what's
up what do you guys say what did you see
me from and I was like I saw you I say
because of you guys now people know how
to imitate Korean people oh cool no but
I knew how to imitate a Korean person
prior to that video that they made Wow
so the whole life nobody understood that
voice cadence unless you were Korean or
Japanese or something but they knew how
to do it very [ __ ] well and after
that [ __ ] everybody started making fun
of great people and I was like [ __ ] dude
nothing so they were the source of that
[ __ ] they actually were the father of
like really getting that Korean accent
out Oh crazy yeah because nobody else
could do it as well Wow
the first video that I saw it was the
the boyfriend one which was not well
were they're like hey what's up my
boyfriend yeah Rick isn't it yeah yeah
yeah just calling each other like you
know how girls calling each other like
girlfriends maybe like yeah that's my
boyfriend right there all dad for my
boyfriend I remember dying at that that
[ __ ] was so funny and then the [ __ ] one
where they just said [ __ ] situation I
was like dude they're [ __ ] hilarious
when
how did you first meet Casey so I met
Casey because I used to love listening
to wax like oh yeah music that was I was
a wax fan and so I would go to his shows
and and then that's where I met Casey at
one of the shows cuz my ex introduced me
to act to wax and we would listen to his
stuff all the time and every time he
came out with a new like CD or whatever
it was we would always get it and but I
couldn't go to his shows early on
because I wasn't 21 yet and his shows
were always 21 and over in LA and so
finally when I turned 21 I went to one
his shows and then that's when I met
like Jay and a K because they were doing
like BTS of his shows and then Casey was
there I was like oh dang that's so cool
like I get to meet the people that are
behind creating his music videos cuz I
was a big fan of his music videos and I
remember following them all on Facebook
and just like on Facebook we would like
each other stuff and then one time Casey
sent me this message he's like hey I
forgot what he wrote exactly but bottom
line is he was complimenting me on my
amazing smile he was like oh yeah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] boy yeah and he was pretty
much saying like hey you know I work on
like a lot of music videos and
commercial work and I would love to have
you featuring and want some something of
mine and I remember at that time I was
with my ex and we were eating at a
restaurant and I like I got the
notification on my phone for the
Facebook message and I read it and I was
like oh my gosh she's actually like oh
my god and I remember feeling these like
butterflies in my stomach but I was like
hold on cuz I'm gonna Lorelei's [ __ ] I
was like no just no you're not feeling
these feelings yeah [ __ ] push those
butterflies now fool No so then but it
was funny because my boyfriend at the
time got so jealous of course he was it
was so jealous and I was just like but
why I'm not gonna leave you for him like
Hello I wanna [ __ ] wax man yeah so I
don't know then that was like what
really hit it off because at that time
he was vacationing in France with his
family and so that's like one like the
first link to France that we had and
that's
we got married out there because I'm the
second link was when we first had when I
first met his parents and they met Isaac
we went to a French restaurant in
Hollywood it was just like all these
little like things that linked us to
France but anyway yeah that's how we met
through wax and and yeah like we were
just really started connecting online
and then once my boyfriend I had broken
up there was another whack show coming
up and I was like hey Casey are you
gonna go to wax his show did you try to
get on that Chinese [ __ ] bandwagon do
you wanted to see ya know Casey yeah he
was the first guy that really gave me
those butterflies where I was like cuz
honestly I had like the worst track
record remember I'm in too deep TIFF
like I just for some reason we've been
into relationships with guys I wasn't
even into and I'm like how did I get
here I'm tonight so what what how long
were you with this other guy for damn
[ __ ] three [ __ ] yeah three years it
was crazy because we actually got
engaged towards the Anthony I know and I
was like he proposed in public like
there was no way I could have said no
especially being in too deep TIFF there
was no [ __ ] way with your personality
back in the day obviously no but I've
literally seen on Twitter where somebody
was like not in public had like the
whole flower was sold even got like a
sound guy in a camera guy and I'm like
whoa that's crazy guys [ __ ] dumb too
because he should have known like how do
you not know because usually girls are
not very subtle when they want a
proposal yeah I mean they're pretty out
there you know what I mean like Mara was
the type of person where like I remember
this wasn't even a sign it was like a
[ __ ] Foghorn in the face and we I was
just chilling I [ __ ] tell the story
all the time where it's like a glass of
water I was like can you pass me that
glass of water I'm thirsty she's like I
don't see a ring on this finger on my
wife what is that got to do with the
glass of water I'm thirsty
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] but you really
weren't talking about it she goes I
don't see a ring on this finger I'm like
I'm sorry what
I mean I was like maybe I should propose
to her maybe she wants a ring I think
that's a sign did that's funny [ __ ]
aggressive so you wrote together with
for three years what you can't save me
oh that's his name you did okay shut the
[ __ ] up all right you know we're gonna
do we're gonna [ __ ] blank that [ __ ]
out
hey watch that [ __ ] dude debut cell has
editing on this podcast we're not gonna
say his [ __ ] name so you were
together with Archibald exactly what
calm Archibald so you're together with
Archibald for three years yeah dude I
was actually trying to break up with him
like a few months in cuz I'm like this
guy is not the kind of guy I want to be
with cuz he was on and you figured that
when the first two days later it was
like two months that's when we got like
our first crazy argument world's like aw
man this is not the situation I want to
be in how do we get here cuz he was
actually a really close friend of mine
and it just it was I don't know man I'm
a really broken person like if I need
love I will gravitate to the first thing
that is giving me love and that's pretty
much my past like that's how I was a
person just kind of came in at the right
time exactly like you just wanted
somebody there and then our chief Archie
comes right Archie comes in and he's
like hey like what's up like we were
friends were like you know like two
years another level okay
ya know yeah I don't know I was I mean I
was 19 I didn't know what I was doing
that's crazy because three years is such
a huge chunk out of your life yeah and
you weren't happy throughout a majority
of it hmm I really wasn't but me what
was so hard for you to be like hey this
isn't gonna work out Isaac because he
was in Isaac's dead and so he really
hung Isaac over my head a lot like he
really manipulated me to stay with him
because of Isaac like how would he do it
so he would tell me things like well you
know you're a single mom who's gonna
love you with a kid dad do you know how
to pick some great guys dude that's a
fantastic man right there dude yeah so
he would say that or he'll be like um
like yeah look at my my parents look at
my family look at look at how much we
love your son like who else is gonna
love you like that who else is gonna
accept you and your son
so I'd be like cool yeah I I felt really
dropped so he kind of just made you feel
like you weren't important enough to
find love elsewhere outside of him
because he would be the only person to
accept a single mother exactly that's
how he made me feel and he was also five
years older than me too
so he was I felt very like now in
retrospect I look back and I'm like wow
like he really just knew how to
manipulate my mind and really try to
trap me and keep me because once we
broke up and I finally had it like
because we had broken up a million times
but he always manipulated me in a way to
continue to be with him so at this this
last time it was like we're breaking off
this engagement there's no [ __ ] way
I'm marrying you there's no way like you
know I can't marry you yeah and he
started stalking my home and he would
text me he'd be like hey like who's that
who's car is that parked outside your
house I'm like it's my aunt like chill
like relax and he was just like really
clingy and I was considering moving to
San Diego to get away from him because I
had no other way out I was just like I
don't want to be with this guy he's
forcing me to be with him like it's been
three years my son already sees him I
was like a father figure because he
really made sure that he encouraged
himself in I six why it was really using
him as a weapon like if I know that she
doesn't love me but if this kid loves me
she won't leave me if yep the kid is
attached to me exactly and that's
exactly what happened in the part that
really angers me the most or used to I
really I'm fine with it now like I did
my Archy suck my nuts [ __ ] but the part
that really would get me is after we
broke up he didn't he never said goodbye
to Isaac he never asked to see him ever
again
he never even blinked like never asked
nothing you know that's the part that
really hurt me the most cuz I'm like
damn I was stuck with you because of the
attachment that you said you had with my
son and now look at what happened after
we broke up and it only confirms that he
really was using him yeah that's so
[ __ ] crazy and you said he was a
friend first yeah we were really close
we were really really close friends how
did you meet him so
I've actually never told this part
publicly but because I feel really bad
about it but the way we met was he was
business partners with Isaac's dad oh so
there was a moment where all four of us
so he had a girlfriend and all four of
us were best friends like we hung out
all the time actually
she was we shared a room together me and
his ex-girlfriend oh wow yeah like we
were tight tight and once I got pregnant
you know I moved out with Isaac's dad
and then the girl she was staying with
Archibald until she turned 18 because
she was actually a runaway and she was
living with him from the moment she was
16 up until she turned 18 and when she
turned 18 she said peace like I'm out
and so she was using him that whole time
that they were together so that was
crazy and so we actually found comfort
with each other because I had broken up
with Isaac's dad and then he had broken
up with his girlfriend and like we were
still really good friends and just as
two broken people yeah in that in that
moment of weakness we ended up just
finding each other and we kind of
created a life together for those three
years but yeah I feel really bad when I
think about the origin of that because
well why do you feel bad about that I
feel bad because Isaac's dad we actually
recently like maybe a year ago squashed
it but he really held on to a lot of
anger and sadness because that was his
best friend too at the time so they
weren't able to make it their business
thing work out so they had a falling-out
because the business failed and on top
of that he personally felt like this
dude came in and like swept up his
family too and so I felt for Isaac's dad
because I'm like him like I can see how
that's really traumatic to for for him
and his experience but and then plus I
feel kind of like because I really pride
myself into knowing that I'm a really
loyal person yeah and and so like just
thinking about how me and Archibald
started I feel like I was disloyal you
know like I feel bad about that that
part of it where
feel like down like you know out of
everyone I could have turned to did it
have to be that guy you know it's hard
though because I think you you had a
very rough upbringing yourself and we're
all finding this out especially when we
get older we are clearly an extension of
the stuff that we experienced when we
were younger we just don't realize it
till we're older like we always think
that we're we're gonna do better and be
better than all the experiences that we
have when we were kids and mind you we
are right but there's still it kind of
just were just a better form of the [ __ ]
version that we had before right mm-hmm
so I kind of realized that with my
parents too like I say my dad's super
rough bah bah bah blah he's done all
this other stuff but could you only
imagine what his father was like and
that he was he's like a million times
better than him right and so now I have
to pick up that same torch and try to be
better than what my father did my
father's a great guy by the way I'm
you're saying like he just had a lot of
flaws that my grandpa had that he
carried on with him and now I have some
of those flaws too but with every
generation if you are very conscious of
the the type of flaws that you don't
want to keep you just become better and
better right and so even for you to it's
not like you're your household growing
up was was a stable household right your
parents split really early when you were
younger yeah and so you know that that
thing is like something that we don't
realize is well we don't know or we
don't see a stable household
what are we basing it on yeah like what
the [ __ ] are we basing what a stable
household is and so when I even when I
would date some of these girls when I
was younger the one thing that is very
cyclical that I would always see
constantly was the ones that grew up in
a broken home
tend to for this is a completely
anecdotal by the way I'm not using this
as a blanket statement but their
perception of what a healthy
relationship wasn't what I thought a
healthy relationship was right so it was
you have to do that the one that I ran
to constantly was um they had a
definition of what a man should be if
they didn't have a father and they're in
their life because this is what a man is
and in my mind I'm like who the [ __ ]
told you that's what I meant was you
know I mean like I'm I'm the male and
I'm telling you that a guy doesn't
always have to be this macho [ __ ] guy
but then then they're like no guy has to
take care of this this and that on my
whole media it's really cuz that's
that's where we learn it from if there's
no one directly in our lives that is a
direct example of what it should be yeah
we learn it from the media mmm and this
it was so weird I remember I had a
conversation one of the girls I dated
and she was like oh you're supposed to
be a man you're supposed to do all this
type of selves like no
what a dad is supposed to do I'm not
your [ __ ] father like I'm your
[ __ ] boyfriend so you got to do this
you got a deal office or the [ __ ] and
like the [ __ ] who do you who are you
talking to right now and yeah obviously
we broke up but yeah that's that that's
that weird part I may think for you too
it's like you feel bad about kind of
like the choices that you made but what
example did you have to not make those
choices yeah and like I said like broken
people always try to fix other broken
people too because you feel like nobody
understands you except for this one
person because they're going through the
same thing yeah you know so and he did a
great job of letting you know hey you're
broken remember like who's gonna [ __ ]
take this broken woman yeah and so when
you were with him and you met Casey was
Casey like one of those like oh this is
refreshing this guy told me that nobody
would want me but look at this guy right
here yeah you know that wasn't really a
thought I had probably subconsciously I
definitely probably felt that with Casey
though it was a breath of fresh air
because like I said he was really the
first guy that I felt attracted to and I
got excited to be near and he actually
liked me back too cuz even in school
like every time I had a crush I was I
never ever told my crushes that I liked
them or even let them know that I liked
them so then I would never end up being
with a guy that I liked I always ended
up being with the guy that told me that
they liked me so I'd be like okay well I
guess this guy likes me even though I'm
not really into this guy like that was
me in school like in high school and
stuff
and so I just never knew what it was
like to be with someone that I also
liked and that they liked me back so
weird the [ __ ] are you saying you broke
and asked woman dude but no special he
didn't want it yeah and then I also
found him attractive too cuz I was like
one of the things I had never really had
oh my god woman what are you saying
right now what if what the [ __ ] are you
saying I just was not physically
attracted to a lot of the guys I ended
up being with but I don't know that says
a lot could case it was pretty greasy
back and say dude this is all gonna be
like
I don't know what these things look like
but now I just picture a pile of garbage
with two eyes so funny I mean I don't
know I don't wanna comment but that's so
[ __ ] funny dude because if we look
back at some of these open up about all
of us we're like damn dude look at that
[ __ ] huh I mean like I've never been so
physically attracted was it what is his
mustache in his earrings I got you [ __ ]
was it honestly the first thing was like
his the size of his body I mean he
wasn't like a bigger guy cuz somehow I
ended up being with bigger guys really
like really big dudes yeah and they're
short not all like not super short but I
mean yeah all these fat guys are like
think about me when they see me [ __ ] I
don't know I don't know I'm with the guy
that just fits into a regular shirt like
it's crazy he just breathes normally
when we sit next to each other he
doesn't breathe out of his mouth only
it's crazy
oh that's so [ __ ] funny dude yeah so
you're just with this normal looking
dude and you're just like tits guys
[ __ ] fine his booty doesn't touch my
feet
[Laughter]
oh my god no no I know and then so
that's what makes me feel like I don't
know man like Casey night we're so good
but we're also so different
yeah and a lot of ways way different -
yeah polar opposites like we grew up so
differently and so whenever we have our
differences come to light it makes me
kind of think like down like are we a
good match like I don't know sometimes I
doubt it because it's really hard to to
think about the origin like the
beginning of when we started like was
this a good foundation you know
sometimes when I think about it you know
Muriel and I are very very different to
you though we're young you've seen us be
complete [ __ ] opposite hey she and i
are nice [ __ ] day but you know we
always make it work yeah you guys get
along really well
you know like I think like I think
that's the thing that people do notice
about me and her a lot they're like you
know we've been together for five years
but always joking around 24/7 that's how
we just are in general like when she
comes home I'm always because the thing
that I mean Muriel's cute right but [ __ ]
all that other [ __ ] right like I you
guys you guys even know me like I we
just had a conversation at lunch right
like I understand what women are
attracted but you never see me really
like drool all over women you know I
mean like it's never been that case for
me like for me and Muriel the reason why
we were even that we're so [ __ ]
different is that I can always count on
to number one make me laugh no matter
what she makes me [ __ ] laugh all day
you know I think that's why I like her
so damn much I even told her like
recently I go if you die I hope you know
I'm dying to there's no other way
there's I'm not gonna I'm not gonna redo
this thing like it's just it's nice that
I found somebody that understands me
because number one she grew up
internationally just traveling all over
the world her parents and my parents are
[ __ ] different dude and I grew up
really poor and kind of in a ghetto
situation you know but at the end of the
day I think like despite all that other
stuff it's more like fundamentally we
make each other happy and that's the
that's the important part right so I
think like my biggest thing that I've
always told you or anybody else well
from what I've learned from these
relationships see my parents love cuz
they my parents fought all the time
again was that there was always effort
people are always trying to be better
right so there's never this moment where
it goes too far right or too far left I
mean people you know fights get big but
there's always somebody trying to figure
out why these things aren't happening
and collectively we're all working
towards the same goal so if I had that
that's fine because I know a lot of
people who are in relationships who
don't try they just go [ __ ] this is
who I am
[ __ ] move on right and that's the
hard part but I always see you guys
putting that effort in you know yeah
that's true that's the part like that's
the other side of my head whenever I
start having these doubts or I'm like
I'm like did I like already these are we
really gonna work out because I mean in
a merry
just I don't know I can't speak about I
can't speak for everyone but in my
marriage I definitely feel like
sometimes there are moments where I'm
like no is this gonna work but then what
I realized is everyone goes through that
and it's the most normal thing ever and
then that's one the other side of me
comes in and says like yeah like exactly
what you're saying like there's effort
put in we do make each other happy there
are gonna be ups and downs and it's just
the most natural and most normal thing
ever and then I end up feeling better
I'm like okay good yeah we we did good
we because then it sucks to get into
that headspace where after you've made
such a permanent decision then you start
doubting it yeah that's the part where
I'm like wait why is my head doing this
right now like you're good like we're
good we're happy we're building a
beautiful life why do I have to doubt it
and I think it's that self sabotaging
side of me that I think has developed
after just being [ __ ] over so many
times in my life where I'm just like
well I mean this is gonna happen you
know so do you feel sometimes that
because of all the bad things that
happen to you do you feel almost like
you're you're such you're undeserving of
your situation that you have survivor's
guilt oh [ __ ] yeah yeah I definitely do
you know like I think we just had a
conversation with a Stephanie Hsu about
that where she feels like why do I get
to have all these great things and we
call that survivor's guilt right because
in your case
- you didn't realize like how great your
life would unfold right this wasn't even
a part of your plan there are people in
this world who aim to be where you're at
and you you've arguably you know I would
say just fell into it you've worked hard
for what you had but it wasn't something
that was a part of your life that you
expected and so like you know we we had
this thought sometimes of like what
would have happened if I did if this
didn't happen do I even deserve to be
here or there are more talented people
out there that would be do better in
this space than I wear them what I do
even want to be in this position in the
first place right this podcast is
brought to you by purple my friends if
you don't know what purple is purple
makes the best mattresses on the market
because that thing will caress your body
like nothing else don't you dare bless
your body with nothing else but a purple
mattress because it won't be a blessing
because it's not a purple mattress a
purple mattress is both
and firm at the same time it's hard to
explain but it's something that you need
because you don't want it too soft and
you don't want it too firm and much like
that porridge son you want it just right
purple mattress by the way is also
developed with some rocket science
technology and that's not me biessing
that's some real stuff and if you want
to try it out check it out
there's a hundred night a risk free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your mattress for a full
refund that's insane
backed by a ten year warranty free
shipping and re turns you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this repo is a text brain to
eight four eight eight eight
that's be are a I and eight four eight
eight eight yeah all those thoughts are
so true and that's definitely something
that my mind gets into that headspace
sometimes and recently though I have
gotten a lot better in silencing that
negative voice because just having such
an amazing group of friends and support
like to really fall back on and like you
know you guys are always there to be
like girl what are you talking about
like why is your head even getting going
there I'm like yeah that's right wait
what what am I thinking about no this is
I did work hard for it cuz when you were
saying like how your life just fell into
this but then you ended up giving me
credit for and you said well you did
work hard for it immediately my mind was
like yeah I did fall into it I didn't
work for this [ __ ] how the [ __ ] did I
get here but then I have to like it's an
internal struggle by giving yourself
that credit and like loving yourself and
having like empathy for yourself and
it's it's hard I think for the hard part
for some of the girls in the situation
like for example you there's there's you
there's Jess people like well or even
like Gio they're like well they you know
they attach themselves to the right
[ __ ] people I've read those type of
comments yeah thanks Liam card yeah they
come hard you know and it's so funny how
you know people all to also to know they
like to discredit people for the success
that they have because they want to be
in their shoes you know they feel like
they deserve
what somebody else has which is like the
dumbest [ __ ] mind state to ever have
you know it's like there you go it's the
ego it's like it's not your situation
and if you feel like you desert or you
could do just a good then didn't [ __ ]
do it dude
yeah go [ __ ] find yourself a nice
agent doing the [ __ ] you should have
done it a nice greasy Asian man that's
right she took the chest she saw that
mustache and that dirty ass her earrings
she was like that's my ticket right
there no but you know where she met when
she met Casey and uh you know Bart and
Joe we're all broke as [ __ ] just to let
you guys know just to let you know
inside joke
you know we uh we were broke as [ __ ] we
Bart was living in this extra house that
his mom had they were making $1,000 a
[ __ ] month dude people don't even
know that barn Joe are making $1,000 a
month and Casey was getting paid more
than they were taking away so there was
no money at the time and then you know
there was a couple of dramatic things
that happen within the group that caused
us to flip and decide to really focus on
earning a wage and then things started
to turn over for us but for the longest
time like none of us was making we were
making any money at all [ __ ] was rough I
would I had I think I was making like
500 bucks a month at that point I know
you know what recently I had this
thought that made me feel like so proud
and so like it's just so happy for
Parton Gio because I started thinking
about when I first met them why am I
getting emotional I don't know I'm
getting emotional sorry but that house
that you're talking about they like baby
the room was just the mattress remember
yeah yeah yeah and like I don't know why
you're thinking it's so good to see it
but seeing their home now and I'm just
like god damn I'm so proud of you guys
I mean you guys had that same thing
though I mean you guys are it's it's
crazy like when I see these these things
that happen all the time that's why I
like I don't know if yours I'm always
like I'm always happy to see you guys
all the time right and I think that's
the great thing about being a part of
this group is when when I see one of you
guys do really well
it makes me feel good right yeah like so
like you
guys getting engaged and like just
seeing everyone's lives and especially
seeing from like from when we met yeah
and seeing the growth it's like oh my
god I'm so proud of you guys like
especially cuz you know I love you guys
so much and it's literally like your
brother or your sister just succeeding
you know so happy yeah for all of us to
you know even when we start these
businesses stuff you know
Jobar all but we will never like oh
we're gonna disinvestment it will blow
up and see what happens it was literally
even Jo put it to he was thinking of a
way in case JK didn't work out or else
our stuff didn't work out that we were
gonna find a way to make sure that
everybody had something right and so
that's what those businesses were for it
was like a retirement plan for employees
right and so I think that's the one of
the greatest things that we have in this
group is that when we see success in our
friends it makes us feel successful as
well it doesn't take away from who we
are as people it's like oh [ __ ] one bar
remember when Barton Gio got their first
house I was so funny yeah I don't know
why it's not my house I think you should
I mean it's not like I I have a kid or
something but watching them being able
to do this is it's pretty [ __ ]
amazing and we know a lot of personal
stuff where they've been through a lot
of struggles and to see where they're at
now even like you know like even Gio to
when we're hanging around tight guys
she's like oh he's crazy
but for some reason I think it's cuz I
just love that kid so much doesn't
bother me
I mean because I think it was somebody
else's kid it'd be like this kids
[ __ ] insane but no matter what Tyco
that does it's probably just because I'm
an extension about how much I love them
when I look at tycoon he's being crazy
I'm like that's so [ __ ] cute no
there's no wrong like like if you do no
wrong he's he's just the cutest yeah
because I was looking at it because we
just went camping this past week yeah
and then we were what I was you know
Tiger was doing his crazy stuff and I
she was like she's so exhausted cuz
she's watching him all the time she goes
ah I'm so sorry there's probably were a
lot more fun thought tiger and I was
like I don't know if that's true because
it he didn't not a single time that he
bothered me he even picked up dirt and
thrown in my tent yeah oh we got there
he went through my channels like what
cute son of a [ __ ] I can't believe you
to pick up dirt and throw it in my tent
they're so cute I was like that's like I
should
upset that I'm United mean but yeah you
kind of look at how we all started in
and where we're at right now and it's
this is pretty freakin amazing man you
know I don't know like I'm actually
surprised I got so emotional
cuz I'm I did have that thought and I
didn't cry when I was thinking it I'm
just saying it out loud Pastor David
Mann honestly I can't even give you all
the credit I cry in everything I'm sorry
guys if I made you cry see I've been
making everyone great you like the 12th
person that cried on this podcast you
know I did I think it is the couches are
comfy because a lot of podcast I feel
like they have like this like a table
and you sit at it like I wanted this to
just be very conversational everybody to
be relaxed and low and behold this was
supposed to be a comedy podcast and it's
not turning out to do that [ __ ]
funniest podcast
none of these episodes is funny I think
I could be funny somewhere else but it's
just real conversations you know but
yeah cuz I look back and I see how how
everybody specifically even like you and
Casey how you guys started into where
you guys are ending up right now and
it's pretty crazy I always look at your
guys's background cuz I'm very blessed
in my sense no matter how crazy my
childhood was I still had both my
parents around so I got to see these
people work out their differences and
stick together and you never had that
and now you're trying to figure out how
to do that with this family right yeah
and then you found a guy who truly truly
loves your child isn't his blood child
yeah you know and I think like in those
moments when he was you know when he
everyone Isaac was at the wedding
specifically mm-hmm you know and he was
calling him dad instead of Casey awesome
whoa that that threw me off or I was
like whoa look at this moment right here
and that just watching that unfold was
in saying I mean I'm pretty sure growing
up - did you ever think that you were
gonna meet this Asian dude get married
in Paris
[Laughter]
that's why you know you're talking about
survivor's guilt I'm like I don't I
think I've moved past the point where I
don't feel like I've deserved
I deserved my life anymore cuz that's
just like an ugly hole to be in but yeah
like for a long time I was like I don't
I don't deserve this life like whose
life am i living you know like this is
crazy I got married in Paris like what
are you talking about that
what like I better smoke was so
interesting cuz I was like man did it
because you guys did a great job of
keeping your wedding really small right
because I'm having the hardest time do
they share that list is [ __ ] huge
nation wedding
no it's cuz I've kept friends for so
[ __ ] long I had the same friend since
I was like [ __ ] 5 or 2 years old Wow
like we still keep in touch like you had
Ray Ray's great ray and I have been
friends since I was 2 years old and
we're still good friends
I keep friends for a very [ __ ] long
time which is why we just want the type
of person is like if I [ __ ] with you I
[ __ ] with you for life yeah if I hate
you I hate you for [ __ ] life
I mean I stick to my [ __ ] guns like I
like dislike somebody it's it's highly
apparent which isn't a lot of people
yeah I mean it's like a very small sect
of people that I might really really
dislike but then everybody else I
generally like and if I keep a friend
for a long time I keep them you know
that's why I like when the during these
whole the whole wedding thing it's funny
when I would get these random messages
especially after this engagement video
popped up right bunch of messages like
yo bro when's the wedding and I would
just write back wasn't matter to you I
have to say that I'm saying in a joking
way kind of for real - yeah you know
because in my mind I'm like The Audacity
why the [ __ ] would you come to my
wedding do the [ __ ] are you did know
people don't realize because any realize
this until I was planning a wedding but
you pay for every person that shows up
every head has a price tag yeah it's
like oh [ __ ] you're a hundred bucks
you're a hundred bucks they're like what
about my plus one
[ __ ] your plus one dude I don't know
them and if you guys aren't married
they're for sure not coming so I guess
my girlfriend [ __ ] your girlfriend dude
how about that you guys just started
dating [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what I think it's like like even
my friend he just had to he'd said I
don't have a plus-one I'm not like aw
come on man I'm like whatever dude I
told no you ain't go she goes I don't
give a [ __ ] like cool go on and I just
go about the wedding cuz it cost money
man dad the people have this weird thing
where I find it weird when people don't
know their position in their friend's
life
right like there's a group of people if
I didn't get invited to the wedding I'd
be like that's kind of weird right but a
majority of it it's not right so there
was another YouTube brought oh you have
two who had a wedding and my friend
like oh so are you going to his wedding
and I'm like no he didn't invite me
they're like oh [ __ ] like it's nothing
happened I was like no I don't think
we're that close yeah yeah it's like
just cuz we got drunk together a few
times doesn't mean that we're really
close friends yeah that's what would
happen it's like I would meet these
people we get drunk and I'm a very happy
drunk yeah I know David yeah I have the
nicest human being on [ __ ] earth
right and so next thing you know like
they people I got invited to be this is
a crazy [ __ ] right actually did a video
on this words this dude asked me to be a
part of his bridal party or his groomed
groom how are you her groom party yes to
be the ring bearer
be a groomsman yeah and I was talking
him on the phone and first of all you
know how I got my [ __ ] phone number
that's the real part right and he goes
hey man like hey I would really
appreciate if you uh be a problem you
know I'm paraphrasing right now but and
I was just like Amen congrats but nah
you know I mean my god like I don't I'm
not that close to you Brian he goes what
he said to me which [ __ ] entertained
me he goes a man like to be honest with
like it's like it should be a pretty big
honor you know that that's for Batum
he's an honor that he asked me to be a
part of his [ __ ] and I'm like who the
[ __ ] you know I was like wrong I
listened to him I said bro I don't know
you drunk a couple times and we're
connected through this other friend yeah
but and then I called him up you know
the guy that canal say yo did he are you
a part of his [ __ ] like are you one
of his groomsmen he goes yeah I was like
are you guys even close he goes not
really cuz nobody asked me he goes bro
he's weird like he doesn't actually have
a lot of close friends so you know the
few times that you guys drink he thought
you guys were buddy-buddy and I'm like
[ __ ] no guy you could if that guy died
tomorrow I literally would shed a tear
that's how little I know him like if you
died I'd be like well [ __ ] Jerry's
dead move on is they thought Jerry by
the way okay good did slip up earlier
yeah that's why we had the magic of
editing be good yeah well [ __ ] because
that's what I'm saying like people don't
know their position yeah your life and
it's very odd where they go it's because
people use that term that's my friend
very easy right like that's my friend I
school oh no I know
yeah I mean but yeah I don't know what
that shit's about I'm pretty sure that
probably happens to you a lot especially
because where you came from and then
people are like oh that's you know
that's tissue she's my homegirl you know
now they see like you're in the
limelight now yeah I was about to ask
you do you think he was inviting you for
the clout maybe but he wouldn't want if
he if I actually went to that wedding
that whole wedding I would have
embarrassed him I would have grabbed the
mic and I just roasted this dude for it
in a full [ __ ] out I got so drunk
once at a wedding where one of my
friends was giving the worst best man
speech I know booing I was there because
I get to go yeah i roasted i roasted the
[ __ ] out of this fool on the mic you
know I mean like that's the last thing
that you want me to do because I'll say
that what are you interested yeah took
that [ __ ] away man cuz I feel like for
you that might that might happen a lot
yeah you know it's funny I have cousins
coming out of the woodwork they're like
hey you know what be friends with your
diello with the cousin and the theme
that goes in awhile that's like
literally so many times remove that
we're not even like we don't share the
same blood but they're still coming at
me like hey and then my mom's telling me
she's like hey so this this other pretty
much of yours they want your phone
number and I'm like mom you better not
give my phone we're out to these people
I don't know them yeah I'll give a [ __ ]
if they're related but they're not
related I mean I didn't grow up with
these people we get it that's the
funniest one is where these all these
cousins from all these other angles are
coming out and saying hey I think is too
when people come out and they're like yo
man I'm I'm so [ __ ] proud of you I'm
like proud of me for what bro what the
[ __ ] are you did you know me like that
[ __ ] are you saying right now man
they're proud of you David are you proud
of me
okay go good job proud of you too you
[ __ ] loser hell man
like it's because they want something
and it always comes down yeah always
comes out later on right it's like odd
they say no I just wanted to
congratulate we talked about you being
all stuck up and then later on it's like
yo man like I'm going through some hard
time getting some money it's like oh so
there it is you want some money lo
behold I'm broke [ __ ] you [ __ ] know
did
thank you huh would you think these
businesses just popped up out of nowhere
that's where all my money is [ __ ]
[ __ ] poor and like stephanie was
talking about this to where she said
like people from back and they just come
up in the ask her for money you know
she's like well I do often I should give
us a no you don't give those people
money because in my mind is like if I
have a surplus of money I'm gonna give
to the people that really do matter that
you can that have supported me and I'll
give it to them they may have to pay me
back I'll just [ __ ] give to them yeah
and it's weird and that's where that
survival survivor's guilt comes from
it's like oh [ __ ] maybe I should give it
away because I don't deserve this money
exactly you know that does happen but
luckily I haven't been situations like
that or else I don't know I couldn't see
myself like Stefan giving money baby
do not give money away good thing
Stephanie she said in the podcast that
she doesn't but she has that guilt
unless her husband is really smart so
he's like now you're not doing that type
of [ __ ] that's dead yeah I mean because
I I just don't like I just hate that
[ __ ] I hate it when people say they're
proud of you because they want something
out you because it kind of takes away
from from the hard work that you've kind
of put in right yeah because I think
that when when we kind of look at our
surface area it's like okay well people
because a lot of people say that they
could do what we do it's like cool
because I would never say that about
somebody else's career yeah right no
that's so interesting cuz like the whole
JK Party thing happening
everyone's like dude I could easily take
over your job like why are you even
there like you're so blah blah blah and
I'm just like oh please please come play
a game with it I would love that
no even people - they're like oh can I
be a guest on your podcast I don't know
who they are but they hit me about the
email no you can't because you would be
the most uninteresting human being on
earth I already know off the bat you
have nothing to say but you literally
have nothing to say like people think
that they have something to say but they
don't they actually don't because not a
lot of people can elaborate on their
thoughts yeah you may have been through
a lot of things but if I bring you on
this place and it's my job to bring that
out of you and the whole time I'm just
exhausted trying to talk to you yeah
it's not going to [ __ ] happen you
know oh you recent I don't even know
about this but I recently had I you're
not doing JK party anymore well I didn't
I didn't talk about it publicly but yeah
I mean behind the scenes I told the guys
like yeah
keep going it's a podcast 9/11 [ __ ]
total it's your fault for not putting it
on silent
hey this isn't Jackie he was right this
is some real [ __ ] no I was the one in
charge of telling everyone who put their
phones on airplane mode all right but
anyway yeah I didn't I didn't mention
this anywhere but Nicky and I we're not
gonna do party anymore because JK Party
fans are really really something they
like they they know what they want and
they know that we're not what they want
so it's like hey you know what at least
for me personally I've been in Turkey
party for so many years and I have I
have learned to stay far far far away
from JK party the entire channel itself
like I don't watch any videos I don't
read any comments I don't go near that
channel because for many years it's been
so toxic they like too from what I used
to be exposed to it's a lot of hate
towards the girls they don't like seeing
girls that have any sort of opinion or
any sort of strategy of playing the game
so any time that any of the girls are
competitive at all like the slightest
bit competitive all their [ __ ] all
they're obnoxious oh my god how can they
take this game so seriously but we're
literally doing the same thing that the
guys are doing it sounds like a bunch of
virgins to be exact I mean honestly if
you think about it these are people that
are watching other people play games
like that says a lot already so it's
like hey okay no worries
you don't want to see us on there at
least for me personally you don't want
to see me on there this is not a fight
worth fighting for me anymore like yeah
especially after this whole drama
because it was this huge ordeal with me
and Nikki were getting so much hate
because we formed an alliance together
and it was an alliance in literally like
two videos where we were it was like us
two against the rest of the people and
it was something like all funny
it's literally fun and games like it's
not that serious but people got really
annoyed about that and so they any time
we were sitting just we were just
sitting next to each other and this
other game and they were mad and hating
that we were sitting next to each other
we weren't even on the sea
team but we were just on like the same
side of the table and we got hate for
that like that's how ridiculous I got so
it sucks because there's we there's this
weird thing on like JK like the JK world
right because even my fan base - JK is
night and [ __ ] day dude like it's
night and day and what I found out later
on was that there's a lot of people from
my fan base that went to JK but there
wasn't a lot of JK people that came over
to my my world because when they would
come the David so fans would destroy JK
and you know negativity and they would
get eaten alive
that's why [ __ ] with my fans so [ __ ]
much right because they are kind of
opinionated and they will defend me a
lot right because they're like there's
the JK world has this weird 2% and they
comment BMO's yeah they're the loudest
they're the loudest totally not the yeah
I wonder % no that's not the majority
but the fact that these loud 2% people
they they tend to form this type of like
mob mentality in the comments and it
reflects in like the the likes and
dislikes ratio of the video and so
overall like like making it Nikki and I
felt like you know what if our presence
here is gonna negatively affect the
channel it's cool we don't need to be
here it's alright like we were here just
to have fun with our friends like yeah
this is not that big of a deal we don't
have to endure this amount of hate
that's coming because it was leaking
over to our personal stuff cuz if it
just lived and party the way it's been
living in party all these years I'm cool
with it like I don't I don't go there
anyway you can hate me all you want on
that channel but when you start coming
to my DMS and commenting on my photos
even photos of Isaac they were calling
me a [ __ ] and telling me that I should
die and I'm just like wow you know what
I don't need to I don't need to go
through this and honestly when those
people come over to my personal stuff
and they start hating on me like that
a good chunk of my brain tells me this
is awesome this is fun this is
engagement because they get to come and
it's so easy for me to just delete block
delete block delete block and they're
there literally creating new pages oh
for sure bothers
yeah they're creating new pages with
like their username as like TIF is a
[ __ ] or some [ __ ] like that and I'm
like oh my god this is so flattering
you're taking all this time and energy
and that's why I love blocking people
because it's so fun for me like it's
because I know and this is a really bad
person I trade in mine that I really
don't care to change because it's
hilarious to me they're like because
people think that oh you blocked them
because it bothers you I guess to a
certain extent well boys we're human
yeah but I blocked them because I know
it bothers them more than speech so like
I so what my favorite thing they [ __ ]
do is that I go I type some [ __ ] right
and then I wait give it like five
minutes because I know that they read it
and they're now they're writing their
response and then I go block so they
can't respond I don't like tight and
then I way from the default something
else I'm like that's probably them too
then I write something really
insensitive
I can wait five minutes again and I
block again this is the fun part for me
right Mary I'll say why are you so petty
I was like I don't know my super vetti
it makes me laugh a lot I don't know why
I just crack the [ __ ] up because my life
still goes on yeah but I know for a fact
for them every day they're gonna be
thinking about a way to get back at me
yeah and I only care enough to make me
laugh which at the same time eventually
it just starts becoming fun but in the
moment it's pretty [ __ ] hilarious
right which is why I like half the time
I just troll people just because it
makes me laugh a lot but only only
people who deserve it not good people
good human beings I don't do this too
but I don't even respond to these people
though because to me the amount of
energy and time and dedication it's
taking for me to delete their clock
their comment go to their page and press
that block that's already too much that
they're getting out of me so they're not
gonna get an ounce more which is me
responding to them so I'm just like you
know what you don't need to live in my
world I can curate my world how I want
it and all these wonderful people get to
live in it and when you come in here and
you try to destroy that you're gonna get
banned and just leave my world alone
yeah I mean I think people have to
understand too they go you should be
above it so well actually you're in my
world so I'll respond however the [ __ ] I
want this is this is this is Davis so
land right you come the Davis soul and
guess what there's some [ __ ] angry as
bouncers here that angry
now is gonna kick you the [ __ ] out right
yeah well that's not the real world
social medias in the real world you're a
hundred percent right
I can curate this world however the [ __ ]
I want you're right it's not the real
world I don't even think it's the real
world but if I want to be happy in the
land that I create I'm gonna be happy in
the land that I create dude I'm Michael
Jackson this is Neverland all right I
had the sole power to admit somebody
into this place but my place has
adults-only and that's the difference
all right no little kids that's the
[ __ ] difference I mean I feel like
disclaimer yeah just to let you know you
know adults only I think for you I think
it's hard because you like I said you
weren't you didn't really make that huge
conscious choice to be a part of this
space so comments are gonna affect you a
lot more yes they did a lot it for a
long time I mean now today I can tell
you that today negative hate comments
they don't hurt me as much as they used
to yeah obviously I'm still human and my
brain is tricked into thinking when I
read these negative things that it's my
brain thinking that about myself so I am
gonna feel a negative emotion about it
but it doesn't like now I'm smart enough
to know that that's not my thought
that's not that's not true they don't
know who I am they're just judging me by
like a very small moment that they've
seen me in and so now I know that I can
handle negative comments and especially
when I can just block them and just
prevent them from coming into my space
to begin with but when I I don't know
like when it's affecting the channel
though like JK party and it's just it's
there's no need for all that like people
can just focus on the fun and games and
if me being there is gonna hinder that
then I don't need to be there it's okay
that's it's we're just like I said it's
just that small amount of people I get
bothered by very few comments like
comments that bother me is usually you
have to do with like race issues or
number two it would be like some kind of
random [ __ ] like Mariel saw this [ __ ]
where I got [ __ ] irritated because
somebody tagged me in this [ __ ] this
Instagram post right and they were
talking some big [ __ ] they were like oh
[ __ ] like I saw David so and I [ __ ]
told him off that he and say [ __ ] to me
I was like me I didn't say [ __ ] I was
like when did this happen I was like who
is this person
hmm yeah and then you know kind of
reflected back on and I was like why
does that know who this person is this
person said hi and then walked away what
and so they mumble they might have
mumbled something I didn't hear that
[ __ ] but you know the way they portrayed
the story was oh yeah I said some big
[ __ ] to David so and he to say she said
this tough guy on line but and person he
was gonna say [ __ ] to me
so I messaged them back I was like hey
so you say some [ __ ] to me I was like
I'm here you could come by any time and
you could repeat what you said we'll
record the whole situation if you're
such a tough guy let's let's talk about
it right cuz I'm still here right so
let's let's talk since this is you know
you know he won though right well this
is what happened right and then Brice
pre writes back he goes he goes because
all brows is really joking whatever I'll
take the whole thing down and I was like
bro
just you don't have to pick it down but
at least be real about your [ __ ] if you
said some [ __ ] to me you wanted to say
something we could we could have [ __ ]
clown on each other all [ __ ] day
let's go let's get it right but he just
you know he was just like oh I guess he
didn't assume that I would have saw it
and I said see it it's like yo bro all
I'm saying that he won in the end
because he got your attention David he
didn't win you know why you didn't let
me tell you that I he I did win why
because I got the sleep you would have
lost sleep over those I really would
have man because it's just not me I was
like did I not say something to somebody
that said something to me that doesn't
sound like a famous soap did that really
I know I know I know this guy he [ __ ]
mumbled something and walked away but I
this happened another time - recently
I'm not gonna say his [ __ ] name which
I don't do which I really wish I should
sometimes but I've been advised not to
for a [ __ ] legal purposes of [ __ ] well
[ __ ] you guy but what does the name
let's let's call him Wang so [ __ ]
Wang right little Wayne little wing I
heard through a couple of other friends
that he so we met up recently he came
and visited and I met up with him and we
were chopping up chopping it up or
whatever in mind you like this guy I
don't even know why I met him up like
he's somebody that I've known for a very
long time and I don't really like him
too much but we were just like friends
des comes up and basically I get a text
like a couple weeks later from one of my
friends and he goes like yo this guy
Wang Wang is saying that you were when
you met up you were being all [ __ ]
weird and like he told you off and I
cursed you out of [ __ ] and he said that
you know you kind of like back down or
some [ __ ] I'm letting you know cuz it
doesn't sound like you cuz maybe my
close friends know who I am right there
like I'll say that what he said I'll say
what the [ __ ] I'll say why do you say
that like we we just had ice cream
together we literally had ice cream
together yeah and we were just chopping
it up but for some reason he was telling
this random story about like how he was
like pressing me and then about some
[ __ ] and I kind of like clammed up I
didn't say [ __ ] and I was like wait wait
what does that mean what usually means
no David it's something you should be so
[ __ ] flattered cuz his dick is this
small and he needs to make exactly a
little wing he needs to make up a story
because you're portrayed like you're
like you said there's no way you
wouldn't have said something right so in
his mind he's making up the scenario
where he feels like he's the big tough
[ __ ] cuz he went up against David so
it's a [ __ ] flattering and it's so
weird to me what the weird thing is it's
like I'm not a mean guy either you know
like you know me like my friends I'm the
nicest [ __ ] friend on earth so I'm
like what the [ __ ] and I started getting
mad because I was like hold on I don't
even like him that much but I was black
bought him ice cream you know how much I
love ice cream oh yeah I bought that
[ __ ] ice cream and he just went off
telling this stupid story and and the
part that bothered me the most was that
I thought he told this story to like a
group of people at one gathering but he
was my god even worse he told individual
people multiple times this random story
and I'm like what what are you saying so
I messaged him and I'm going back home
oh this month I was like hey bro if you
have a problem with me you should have
said something and why are you telling
people this Brandon start he goes all
bro it's not even like that I was like
no it is and a screencap sent it over I
was like so is everybody lying or is it
just you I was like when I come back
well let's talk about it and then we'll
see what's up right
not like will fight but you know
probably came off like that way but I'll
say let it just leave it let it sound
like it's like that he's [ __ ] his
[ __ ] pants right now what did he
think was gonna happen like they just
weren't gonna say anything probably yeah
but then uh inflating his own ego yeah
it was such a weird thing that's the
first time that has ever happened and I
was like I should have never bought him
ice cream dude that's it you're
regretting yeah I regret it I took him
to my favorite ice cream place ah salt &
straw yeah suck and I [ __ ] should piss
me off
it's so annoying well I mean I'm glad
that his lie blew up in his face though
because not every single person that
came to you to do that [ __ ] straight he
looks like the idiot and the only reason
why they came to me because it sounded
so bizarre yeah they're like wait why
would why would David do that it's like
yeah why would I do that
what the [ __ ] like why would I why would
you hit me up i buy you food and then I
talk [ __ ] about you like what the [ __ ]
like we would have a fight about what
this is a lot of the person he is - then
he was doing that [ __ ] was bad maybe and
I'm my thing is - like what do you gain
from doing that - a [ __ ] z-list
celebrity
I'm as low on the totem pole of a
celebrity that you could ever imagine
like I'm at the bottom of the bottom
right and you're trying to gain Fame off
of somebody who's barely on YouTube like
what the [ __ ] are you doing with your
life bro right so here's the sad
pathetic one don't even trip punch me
the [ __ ] face did I just want to
punch him in the face
I love how petty you are though - I was
telling you about those neighbors when
we were looking at the homes there were
these yeah you could tell them you're
good just let them know so they know
about your whole finding a home finding
a home so they look for this house and
in this area when they were looking at
this home there's this neighbor who's
highly highly just pro-trump [ __ ]
immigrants [ __ ] Meg and so they had like
this picketing sign and they faced it
towards Casey and Ted just to let them
know that their kind is not allowed yeah
and then the homeowner decides to get in
his car rev up his car to [ __ ] peel
the [ __ ] out and go around the whole
block just to scare them off and mind
you as an adult that TIFF as she goes
well [ __ ] these people who the [ __ ]
cares about them I'm actually going to
egg their house because Casey wanted to
go up to
and read the sign because they wrote it
so small it was actually kind of hard to
read it is [ __ ] you and Casey are
equally as petty though because he
wanted to go up there and be like sorry
what I can't read your sign why does it
say and you're over there and you're all
like we're gonna go and egg their house
right now I'm gonna no I'm not only am I
gonna take their [ __ ] house I I said
if I was in your gadget situation I
would have bought that house even if I
hate him because my existance next to
them would ruin their whole life that
house is [ __ ] but I love how I would
also bought that [ __ ] house I would
have sat on the lawn every [ __ ] day
and I would have worn a mana hat just so
they can't even hate me even if they
want to I'll be like damn you know what
[ __ ] these Asian people right I [ __ ]
hate slant-eyes you know I'm saying you
know us white people [ __ ] white power
did so funny I had never experienced
racism like that in my life ever that
was the one and only time I've ever felt
that cuz I've always I've always been
around Mexicans my own people just my
entire life it's always been around the
same people and yeah just trying to look
at that house I was like wow these
Monday morning you do Tai Chi in the
front lawn my Tuesday morning mariachi
music today I would do it like the
craziest way she is so common soon not
when I had that annoying Asian violin
playing I would [ __ ] do that [ __ ] all
the time dude I would rent out a taco
cart in the morning and that's what
we're having and I would invite them to
eat every [ __ ] day yeah I would speak
in a [ __ ] like a thick ass East LA
accent to them all the time dude
good morning neighbor I [ __ ] hate
people like that dude that's so [ __ ]
annoying like what does that do for them
I don't know they also have a very small
wing they have to flaunt
I'll show them my small wing how about
that dude I'll do that's so [ __ ]
petty
oh that's so [ __ ] annoying I'm oh god
I'm gonna egg them so bad oh I mean you
can just buy that house you have the
money aren't you so rich you're giving
people money I am going to buy that
[ __ ] house and I'm literally just
gonna stare at them all day I'm actually
gonna tear one wall
down and there's gonna be opening to my
house they could see me do all my Asian
[ __ ] that's funny
oh you stupid sons of [ __ ] have you
ever experienced racism that way I've
you know what like I've had moments of
racism but when it happens because it
doesn't happen often I'm actually kind
of like you where it's just like oh what
the [ __ ] is this it feels weird yeah it
doesn't feel like all I've had this my
whole [ __ ] life
I mean that's where Casey was coming
from though cuz he really did have that
his whole life Oh like he was in a white
neighborhood he was the only Asian guy
for the majority of his like upbringing
so I got where the anger was coming from
but I'm like maybe it's okay just be
above it it's so hard to be above it
when you could be beneath it though
low-hanging fruit dude it's the easy one
to grab and I just want to grab that
low-hanging fruit why do I gotta go all
the way to the top well yeah because
like when I 20 reinstallation like
actually I remember the first person to
ever call me a chick with a black girl
oh and I just was like shocked I was
like [ __ ] call me a chick but she got
kicked out of school because I should
know we had a very low tolerance to
racism you know white people our school
and we had like every quarter we had
like a cultural fair where everybody got
to bring their own food and sell it like
from from your ethnicity or culture so
when that person heard her call me a
[ __ ] she got kicked out of school real
fast bad [ __ ] [ __ ] in your face you
know I own a black piece of plaster I
can hook you up your bracelet or [ __ ] up
yeah everybody's with toy the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I'm gonna hook you up dude but
yeah I don't know like that make sense
for Casey because there's a lot of like
Asian fans who can't relate to what I'm
talking about because or I can't relate
to what they're talking about because I
didn't grow up with that type of racism
so I don't know what it feels like to
always look at to be looked at like
you're beneath somebody else yeah right
cuz I don't I don't know what that is
like so when I see why people I'm just
more like they're probably get robbed
you know that's the only thing I think I
don't really I get uncomfortable around
a group of white people only because I
haven't been around them that's the same
reason why I get uncomfortable too cuz I
remember feeling that uncomfortableness
and I'm like wait why why do I feel so
out of place yeah and I'm like oh it's
cuz I'm just not used to like I totally
felt that when I started dating Casey
and like we were just around nothing but
Asians I'm like wait this is weird I've
never felt this feeling that I'm feeling
right now like that
gasps Asian geo because she was not
Mexican at that time she liked her
ethnicity was hidden and when I found
out she was Mexican my jaw dropped I was
like gay and she speaks Spanish - it's
like what dot oh no I was like what and
then I started remembering all the
situations where I was expressing how
Mexican I was and I'm like [ __ ] you
could have joined me in that
conversation every time you were you
were [ __ ] Mexican daughter you were
Mexican yeah every other word was in
Spanish now I can't even remember my
Spanish dude it was so funny cuz when
Bart told me what her ethnicity was he
goes when I tell you what her ethnicity
is you're gonna understand everything
about it it's gonna click he was like
what are you what is she she's Mexican I
was like [ __ ] add to this yes I make
sense dude she's [ __ ] Mexican as hell
I should have known that so she threw a
chocolate my face so funny what did you
find out first it whether or not uh
Gio's ethnicity or Barton Jose I found
out Gio's ethnicity first I know you
know how I know cuz because they were
they were so hesitant to let you know
their ethnicity because of how bad you
were at keeping Gio's ethnicity secret
well you know what the thing was it's
like I already knew Joe was Japanese
from the jump yeah that's the thing they
didn't know he looks Japanese as [ __ ] it
was [ __ ] funny I never told a single
person he was Japanese but I knew he was
Japanese the moment I saw his face and
he's like yeah people don't know who I
am I was like how the [ __ ] do they not
know who you are you're you're them like
if you look up [ __ ] Japanese Joe's
faces on it dude
you know I've never told anybody that
and then I think like when they said
that they like the JK people knew I
assumed that it was everybody in JK but
me so when we were having these parties
like I was like oh I made a joke about
her being Mexican I see well what am i
and I was like oh did they not know I
know David can't keep a secret don't
tell David wait that's the thing they
didn't know well it wasn't because I
couldn't keep a secret it was because
they'd I didn't know how important I was
to that group
cuz why would I think that David so
who's not a part of JK would know more
than all these JK people so I didn't
know how the relationship of how close
we were until that moment
and they're like no they don't know I
was like well you told me JK knew their
JK so how was I supposed to know you
know they're like yeah only these did
only the clothes JK people knew and so I
was like oh Tom
Tommy's Jacob their JK and I didn't know
what the relationship was you know I
mean so I assumed that everybody knew
but me and I was finally the last to
know
so when I found that I was it Oh so they
meant jake hasn't these JK yeah so
that's where I [ __ ] up I was like oh
[ __ ] and that's when I stepped up I was
like oh they don't actually know yeah so
I didn't know that I was a part of like
this exclusive group that like a few
other members didn't know until after
that moment Joe with Japanese the moment
I saw his [ __ ] face he's Japanese his
[ __ ] dude did you ever talk to him about
it before they know when he told me he
was like he was like when I
I got hyper confirmed when it was in
Hawaii so we're Hawaii his cousin was I
so how long have you been friends with
masa token I was I thought and I was in
the car and then gia was there and I'll
slip the photos I looked at yells like
not though huh
[Laughter]
yeah I was like well that's not what I
found out I was all only hyper confirmed
what his Japanese name was but he was
like yeah I'm Japanese that we can't
tell anybody I probably knew you were
Japanese says look at your face yeah you
have a Japanese ass [ __ ] face so when
people were like oh he's definitely
bidding
there's no Vietnamese guy that looks
like Joe he's a [ __ ] Japanese dude
that's funny yeah so I was kind of I
just didn't know what Bart was
bartlett's Korean yeah Bart is Korean
what looks I know like five people that
look like Bart
so Bart looks Karina's [ __ ] well
according to his 23 years a little bit
2% Korean or some [ __ ] like that
even I am my 23 means is I'm part Asian
I forgot the percentage oh really
yeah oh that's crazy I know I was like
what yeah it's it's shocking let Bart
was the hardest when he told me he was
shy I was almost 100% sure he was Korean
because he knows a lot of inside Korean
joke it's a Korean last name
yeah so it's he's kind of in this weird
like nebulous area of like he could be
Chinese or Korean when I found that out
I was actually shocked his his was
shocking that he was fully Chinese and
and he even told me that he didn't want
to show me that he was Chinese so
because there are times he would eat
rice
and he wanted to lift up the bowl and
put the chopsticks to his face and scoop
the rice in because that would have been
a big sign if I actually hit he's smart
because if I saw him do that I'm like
Chinese Wow able to do that people won't
pick up that [ __ ] like this and eat it
with their face because we're civilized
so his [ __ ] ghetto last refused to do
this and scoop the [ __ ] rice in his
face no no [ __ ] did now he just offers
me food with his dirty ass fingers
fingers he do that at the camping trip
too like there was like the little
strudel the guava cream cheese I was
like there's two left he goes oh I want
to David Lee when I was grabbing my own
he grabbed it for me thanks dude
dirty fingers he's funny that thing that
you pointed out how every time no matter
what if a food a piece of food falls on
the floor he's like don't worry I'll eat
it
nobody asked you bro nobody asked you to
eat that dirty ass food oh I woke up to
that sound so I woke up and all I heard
was no really I was like [ __ ] I
guarantee nobody said who's gonna eat
that is so funny
Bart's [ __ ] hilarious but yeah Jo I
knew he was Japanese from the Jobs's day
one I was just always shocked that
nobody could figure it out I was like I
mean I didn't even I just thought all
Asians were Chinese man I didn't know
[ __ ] yeah and then we had we had another
friend who actually saw Joe's ID before
and it was his original last name then
he had before Jitsu kala yeah and so
that was already the other side and I
actually found that I they told me that
like a year before even I knew him a
year so cuz he knows people I know
people that he knows and they're like
hey do you know what his actual last
name is and they told me and I was like
oh for sure he's Japanese yeah you know
and so when he told me his real last
name I was shocked again I was like wait
it's not that and then I found out later
on that that was his dad's name yeah so
there was a lot of things so I could
keep a [ __ ] secret I kept
that's thinking for many years
yeah in your [ __ ] face dude and let
me tell you something else dude I always
keep my phone on silent on JK news let's
talk about that [ __ ] I was I arguably
people have done it more than me now in
the beginning it was the most later on
it's not being me as much how many times
that Bart a Joe [ __ ] go off Joe I think
maybe twice bar no Joe a lot
no a lot it's you guys have it so stuck
in your [ __ ] head dude really no cuz
I'm the one that has to yell at everyone
so I'm like you just yell you pretty
actively yell at me dude cuz I already
feel like it's your the troubled child
they take something that has a history
you have a bad track record I have a
track record for showing up late because
I enjoy it now it's like it's like my
[ __ ] now 15 minutes late is where I'm
always gonna be at well do you know
originally when we were doing JK news
the reason why I showed up late was
because I always showed up too early in
the beginning I would be waiting outside
in my [ __ ] cut when we first started
JK news back in the day cuz everybody
was show up late so I would be on time
waiting outside and then this was before
Julia would come in early to set up the
cameras and Julie Bates she would beat
everybody but I would be there in my car
so everybody funny Steve is the new you
like in all senses cuz he's always late
to we're always holding a fish shoot for
Steve I'm like Steven come on see
there's always a good replacement did
Steve is holding up that steep don't you
ever show up on time ever oh my god it
was so beautiful because last time he
was so he was pretty damn late and so
Casey right now he has taken over being
like the ad of the shoot cuz I can't I
was going crazy like wrangling everyone
and doing the articles and all that [ __ ]
I couldn't do it so Casey came in and
he's the one that's been making sure
that the shoot moves along and so it was
so funny because we were waiting for
Steve and then once he everyone gets
there I tell Casey I'm like hey can you
give everyone a reminder what the call
time is it's 8:45 people don't show up
till like 9:15 so Casey does this
announcement like all right everyone
especially people on this side of the
table remember the call time is 8:45 and
then the very next shoot day Steve was
the first one there yep in Casey was
late as [ __ ] and that's why we don't
show up on time no no but Steve was like
I will show up early just to rub it in
everyone's faces
he's even pettier than you David it's so
[ __ ] funny so I'm like that's
hilarious yeah like there's there's
these moments that I remember is just me
sitting outside this waiting in my car
for people to show up and also because
when we start JK news what happens is is
like Joe will start a conversation and I
think
8:45 we still start at 9:30 and I'm like
oh [ __ ] man that's why just started
showing up late I was like doesn't
matter where I go start anyways I know
dude
I hate that's why I Casey has to take
over cuz no one listens to me look at
this sweet tender voice because ASMR has
always did I know I should do anything
our home
mariel actually likes hay bits podcast
the most because she likes the way your
voice and boy sounds oh cool this is
very calm and very relaxing and then
Bose comes in and disrupts the booze and
the gin will come in with an idea
[ __ ] Gina will come up with a random
comment it'd be like hey guys yeah so
you know sometimes when it comes in
relation that Gia's like you know what's
good a veiny dick it's like [ __ ] that
come from Gina I know but do you listen
to a [ __ ] though because it's a really
great podcast everyone should try I
personally don't want to listen to you
guys talk about dicks I mean I get it
cuz you're really close to us yeah so
it's a little odd but everybody else
[ __ ] loves it dude I know it's been
so amazing seeing the response no
there's so many people that are hitting
us up and saying like woah like this is
exactly what I needed like a group of
friends that I can listen to even guys
are hitting us up and saying like this
is exactly what I've been looking for
cuz I don't understand women for [ __ ] so
it's been really awesome though you just
got to go to the fire of course but it
also helps hearing the thought process
for sure man yeah and that's because
like for me it's just weird I just yeah
I'm like if you didn't know us though do
you think you would oh it's very
entertaining but then I just don't want
to hear stories about you guys thoughts
on dicks and [ __ ] come in your face
and it bothers me I'm like this is not
big I want to listen to you right now
I'm gonna move on from this right now
but Muriel loves it love oh you were
telling me that Muriel forces you to
listen to us yeah we're like in the car
she goes you want to listen - hey [ __ ]
podcast I was like abso-fucking-lutely
not but you can listen to it as much as
you want
no because it's very at people love it's
super entertaining I think it's fun and
it's a it's it's like a lot of open
conversation between women that a lot of
girls don't have because I think in her
group specifically a lot of girls are
very closed off I know I could tell cuz
when I was talking to Mariel in Japan
and I was telling her a lot of my
personal stuff she's like
she doesn't know anything you're so cute
you're like my little sister
yeah she's like her friends are very
demure and there's a lot of girls that I
like that so it's kind of refreshing to
hear the opposite of that because you
know people have these thoughts but they
don't ever say it out loud and so that I
think that's where that podcast comes in
really handy yeah it's been awesome even
for us too it's been very therapeutic
just for us to get it out there and like
just talk about all these things all
these experiences like I even talked
about some personal stuff that I've
never talked publicly about you know and
it was really nice to see the response
to cuz I got so many themes and people
tweeting at me saying how amazing it was
that I was able to be vulnerable and
open up about certain things that need
to be spoken yeah and I'm just like well
that's cool yeah don't you'd be
surprised
you'd be surprised how much fans can
surprise us with their support right
because we think that sometimes when we
put our information now we might get
vilified instantly oh yeah but people
are a lot more understanding than you
think that they are yes that 2% that
[ __ ] everything you know that 2% is
really loud and then your brain tends to
gravitate to the negativity - so then
like you know for you you feel so
entitled to need to defend what it
whatever it is that they're talking [ __ ]
on and for me I'm just like to him
that's true they're right oh I don't
think it's true at all I think like you
are highly misinformed and I must inform
you that you're wrong and if I ever see
you in public I'm slicing your ankles
off you son of a [ __ ] you know I
definitely feel that to her I'm like God
I wish you just knew the right and like
I wish you knew the truth and then like
that part ends up taking over and that's
when at least for me I'm like okay they
won they already won they got to me like
just to end this podcast on this note
just to talk about untruthful [ __ ] I
will never wear socks on this podcast
ever [ __ ] sons of [ __ ] are wearing
socks they're always like Oh where's
your socks David I'm so petty
I'm not wearing socks anymore you should
tell that ok guys you need to talk you
need to comment and tell David how much
you love seeing his toes and how much
they will our socks a mural you love it
you just love it I will [ __ ] wear
socks tomorrow and then somebody was
like it's like I hate the way your
camera's ankle this should be up so we
could see more of this and I'm like no I
don't like angling cameras up and the
reason
i-it's it's a literally a Quantico
directors choice because when you have
your king the camera angled up number
one it looks voyeuristic it looks like a
camera on the wall the reason why I have
it low like this it looks like you're
sitting here hasn't part of the
conversation that's why I don't look
doing high cameras because high cameras
looks like it's set up so you're
watching other two people talk this
makes it seem like you're at the table
looking at us so in your [ __ ] face
well that wraps up this podcast you
[ __ ] jackasses I had fun yeah that's
great Tiffany what can they find you my
everything is at real underscore TIFF
and then also on YouTube Casey and I
have our Channel
it's Tiffin case and also don't forget
the hey [ __ ] podcast course you forgot
to plug that in Jagger I didn't I
plugged it in earlier but you reminded
me so hey check me on here [ __ ] podcast
as well yeah amazing podcast you guys
catch you guys good today you guys can
catch a the genius brain podcast not the
just genius brain podcast and on Spotify
iTunes stitcher any kind of audio
platform out there we're on there give
us that five star leaving the comments
below what you thought about the podcast
what you thought about tips personal
stories and she all crying appearance
[ __ ] also it's all good man it's on the
couch dude everybody's opening up but it
was great talking to you guys talking to
you TIFF and we'll see you all next time
[ __ ] yeah peace